i'm alicia a developer advocate for
google cloud and in this video i'll show
you how to build a data pipeline with
google cloud
whether you're looking to use data to
perform analytics to build machine
learning models or for reporting and
business intelligence there are several
ways to bring data into google cloud in
this video i'll walk you through an
architecture for one data pipeline
approach called etl or extract transform
load which allows you to maximize
flexibility in how you transform your
data while also providing dynamic
scaling to handle large amounts of
incoming data and processing demands
by the end of this demo you'll have seen
an etl pipeline in action and will
understand the components used including
cloud storage for landing data
data flow as a managed service for
processing data
bigquery as a destination data warehouse
and finally cloud composer as an
orchestration tool that helps you author
schedule and monitor data pipelines
let's get started if you logged into the
console for the first time create a
project
a project is required to use google
cloud and forms the basis for creating
enabling and using all google cloud
services
i'm going to be using this one for our
demo today
in the left-hand navigation select
billing and link your billing account
you can also go here anytime for an
accurate up-to-date picture of your
cloud spend
by clicking view all products in the
left-hand navigation you can view all
products learn more about them read the
documentation work on a quick start and
even navigate to individual products
if you prefer to use the command line
interface to start building your etl
pipelines or other cloud solutions from
the top right corner you can activate
cloud shell
cloud shell is an online terminal
pre-loaded with utilities such as the
gcloud and bigquery command line tools
which allow you to configure and deploy
google cloud resources
now that you know how to navigate
through the console let's look into the
etl pipeline project first let's head to
cloud storage a service for storing
objects in google cloud
objects are stored in containers called
buckets
you can create a bucket in the console
by clicking the create bucket button and
then following the prompts on the bucket
creation form
each prompt includes information to help
you choose the storage location
class and access control policies for
your use case
in the cloud storage browser the first
bucket you see listed is storing all the
files needed for the pipeline
this is where we uploaded the raw source
data we want to make available in the
data mart
the input data in this pipeline is a
text file containing some points of
weather data
to ready the data for loading into the
data mart we need to transform it from a
text file to a json object that adheres
to the schema of the destination table
we have outlined this transformation
using a javascript user defined function
which is also stored in the cloud
storage bucket our etl pipeline is
written to process only this one
transformation
however the architecture is flexible and
scalable to handle numerous and complex
transformations over large amounts of
data which brings us to the next step in
the pipeline processing the
transformation
this is handled by data flow
dataflow is a fully managed data
processing service which allows you to
focus on the logical composition of your
data processing job while data flow
executes the transformation managing
parallel processing coordinating workers
sharding data sets and more
if you're interested in working within
the hadoop ecosystem you may want to
explore using data proc to manage your
data processing
dataproc is a managed hadoop and spark
service that allows you to create and
manage clusters quickly and easily
in fact it can spin up a cluster in
about 90 seconds
then you're ready to take advantage of
all the open source tools you're used to
all right back to our project
in the dataflow ui you can click on the
job to view the execution graph
a pipeline's execution graph represents
each transform in the pipeline as a box
that contains the transform name and
some status information
you can click on the caret in the top
right corner of each step to see more
details
once the dataflow job completes the
transform data is written to the
destination table in the bigquery data
warehouse
bigquery is a fully managed data
warehouse that provides incredibly fast
sql analytics over large data sets by
landing the transform data in bigquery
storage it's ready for downstream use
for jobs like performing analytics
building machine learning models
reporting and more from the bigquery
console you can select the destination
table to see details
including a preview of the first few
rows of data
and click to start writing and running
queries
[Music]
if you would like to try querying larger
data sets click add data and explore
public data sets to see our library of
more than 100 data sets ready for you to
analyze
clicking on a particular dataset tile
will provide you with more details
including a description of the data set
metadata showing information such as
update frequency and even sample queries
so how could you coordinate automate and
monitor these multiple services into a
pipeline
there are several orchestration tools in
google cloud that can do just that
cloud composer is specifically designed
to orchestrate data-driven workflows
such as batch etl workloads and is built
on the popular open source project
apache airflow
composer is fully managed and allows you
to use python to create schedule monitor
and manage your pipelines
however if your workflow requires low
latency executions or follows spiky
patterns you'll want to consider
workflows
workflows is a fully serverless solution
which means that you can focus solely on
your workflows without exposure to
underlying infrastructure
so while composer is a great fit for
data workflows orchestration
the workflow service is better tailored
for bursty latency sensitive serverless
use cases
finally if you don't need to manage a
complex workflow you may only need cloud
scheduler
scheduler manages the execution of a
single service on a recurring schedule
using cron scheduling you just learned
how to build an etl pipeline on google
cloud by loading data in cloud storage
processing transformations with data
flow and warehousing your analytics
ready data in bigquery
you also saw options for orchestrating
the pipeline with cloud composer
workflows or scheduler
thanks for watching i encourage you to
sign up for a trial and follow this
tutorial yourself
[Music]